konnichiwa Hashimi maste felix and days
as you can tell after my trip in japan i
have learned some awesome level of anime
skill
Sugoi desu name but with great power
comes great responsibility
and i have finally learned what that
means
the legendary anime creator hayao
miyazaki said anime was a mistake and
now I finally understand his sentiment I
finally understand what he meant
you see what I'm talking about anime
with some mistake what anime was just by
the way sir let's together examine some
of the worse examples of anime victims
any of these that we're about to watch
could have been me okay I feel better
pink but it's so beautiful who is she
[Music]
[Laughter]
Oh
Oh they told loves to collect things
from Japan oh I see is a man of culture
Wow
it's practically my room Sugoi well it
wasn't a LAN it's asterisk are starving
don't be getting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
look at the old man in the background
what what it's too wholesome oh it's
like they don't get it at all and
probably they won't but at the same time
they get that he's on TV and for a
reason so they think it's like in a
different universe this is me it's
Jesus Christ you guys know there are
other enemies out there everything every
time every single time it's always
attack on Titan like it's the only anime
that exists
I can't watch this it makes me sick a
hard time I think going through is
deciding whether or not I'm Japanese
I don't like people are kind of judging
me for this I'm aware of that but like I
feel it in my veins I know who I am and
I think I'm Joplin
she thinks she's Japanese what wiki's
guys she's got some competition it seems
ok ok what's the motivation behind this
conclusion like recently I've been like
reading lots of manga recently I've been
reading and that's a manga and now I
turn into Japanese person I just feel so
part of their culture now oh that
reminds me of the Guru Ganesh guru the
miss I love sushi I love Japan
period girugamesh
like I also really like their food like
sushi sushi it's all that kind of stops
have you heard about this have you heard
about this they put raw fish how what is
it with anime that just draws them out
I'm not sure if it's drawing them out or
if it's transforming people to this
despicable disgusting form one now I can
oh you may wall kaki atsume sagashi mono
sock ashiya-kun osa one piece it's a
dead face and this is the monotone
singing this is beautiful I love it what
what a great talent
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's not nearly as good as his I'm sorry
for even trying okay birthday to you
happy birthday to you happy birthday
Colton oh hi happy birthday to you blow
up the cows Colton oh ha yeah blow out
the candles do it hey wait a minute that
wasn't coat to know huh blowing out
those candles Kyra seijuro wasn't
looking for trouble my god yes I forgot
about this clip this is the sorry okay
let's smile that night the trouble
certainly found him when that fight
broke out he was ready for us with his
trusty katana I actually carry this
because I become a little bit more
dangerous than without it and with it so
it's more of a restraint mechanism than
a safety plan he's carrying around a
katana so that he will restrain himself
because he's more dangerous without a
fight had been going on for about 20
minutes it was two on one none of them
saw Jairo seijuro move around behind
them to them they probably thought I was
just moving out of the way but I was
actually setting up to wear their blind
spot was if he had gone on me I mean he
was setting up the blind spot you were
in the tram there was no one else to be
brought the sword down and then
completely kind of completely gave him
up essentially is that they weren't even
a challenge I already had a pulse full
five-stage plan ready to take everyone
out five stage plan huh damn that's not
bad
that's the way of the samurai you got to
think ahead always have a plan and
anybody else you've got involved just in
case
it was ready to kill anyone else joining
in oh my god if there's one song in the
whole universe that will trigger me more
than anything it's that intro so I used
to know the whole advanced
[Music]
[Applause]
nani mo na nee more my - iran new doctor
food art a career my qu a sec aha
those are to be neither
if you're gonna sing anime at least get
the right pitch at least get the right
tone at least get something right about
it I don't even care if he's memeing
this this is bad this is bad and you
should be ashamed of yourself it's a
wonderful song and you completely ruined
it for me
and I for everyone this is why anime was
a mistake and I hope you've learned your
lesson
leave a like if you enjoy anime and
leave a like if you lose
[Music]
you name it I do tiny no more talk
naturally I like it
[Music]